Louis let me transition now to a topic
that is garnering significant interest
from the audience which is earlier in
the week we revealed that you would be
leaving the david pakman show because
you are no longer looking to be living
in a city nor in a place that has cold
winters and the suggestions for where
you should move have been flowing in
like a deluge of water the likes of
which only Niagara Falls experiences on
a regular basis let me put up well first
before we put up the first list two
types of suggestions some people wrote
in saying hey here's where Luis should
go and we'll put up some of those some
people writing in saying I really don't
get what the hell is doing and basically
saying you know really if you stay
anywhere three to four years you will
like the place because that's how long
it takes to get to like a place and that
was that's been a common reaction from
people yeah that you'll you'll like
whatever place you really settle down in
so to speak I've guys I'm not true I
think there's some truth to that with
some limits I think no matter what if I
settle it well I don't wanna insult any
place but they're they're certainly
places where I'd no matter how much time
I spend I don't know that I would love
it necessarily it don't don't tell me if
I settle into the slums of Jakarta that
after you know after two years or four
years I'll love it there okay let's go
to some of the first suggestions uh Jan
wrote in saying that month the Monterey
Peninsula in California would be a good
option for you Frank wrote in suggesting
Fayetteville Arkansas I don't know that
I see you in Arkansas necessarily Steve
wrote in saying Asheville North Carolina
seems like a good Town to consider it's
close to Charlotte it's warm ish etc
also Northern California Santa Rosa
reading or Eureka Stephanie said San
Luis Obispo is a good idea Madison
Wisconsin and st. George Utah don't
really see you in Utah I must say
Randall saying I helped a friend move to
portland oregon and i thoroughly enjoyed
it during my visit and Royce said cheap
cities to live number one Detroit having
more women and girls certainly one of
the more unusual suggestions we received
what's your reaction to these so far
Asheville as I mentioned was one that I
was considering and that is uh still a
possibility California climate how can
you beat
sure but it's so expensive and i'm still
that's an idea entertain as for the rest
probably not and detroit uh say what you
will about Detroit it does not meet my
criteria because of the the climate
right let's go with that yeah good idea
uh Jason what about this California
stuff in here you're hearing from Lewis
I mean inland it is not that expensive
is it yeah but if he wants to have like
any you know land yeah land or culture
or society you know there's this big
giant uh you know Center Central Valley
of California is fairly desolate very
cheap you have some awesome cities i'd
recommend Bishop California is an
awesome little place but if you want to
like you know have a place to work and
you know do something positive the world
probably not have a lot going on there
but the coast the Central Coast of
California that's my recommendation good
food good weather good people no big
cities not Los Angeles that's another
consideration are you looking to be
working or is that are you basically
done with work I I will need some form
of income okay yeah cuz that's a
consideration as well I think it no they
go yeah doubt no doubt let let's look at
a few more few more examples that came
in uh this page one again let's go to
the second one um where we have just a
few more suggestions Sheeran wrote in
saying you should move near Corpus
Christi Texas I'm starting an ecovillage
there's an idea Suzanne said my
recommendation to Lewis is to move near
eugene oregon population a hundred and
sixty thousand doesn't get hotter than
the low eighties in the summer doesn't
get colder than the mid thirties in the
winter average snowfall under 3 inches
per year you're not really looking to be
anywhere that there's any snow right i
I'm not a big fan of the snow and uh but
I do hear it's very nice over there yep
alright and then look at the last couple
suggestions there uh Janine i recommend
the Bay Area I mean but basically to
totally a non-starter right you don't
even wanna go anywhere near the bay area
I'm voiding that like the plague Cole
said Louis you should move to Billings
Montana buy it i'll be honest i don't
see it and then Stephen Lewis should
move to the durham north carolina area
perfect weather great food we are
actually very liberal outdoor
opportunities in places to leave live
near the city without being in a
metro area it's also fairly affordable
North Carolina keeps coming up and you
do a family there so I feel like on that
whatever imaginary list we envision in
our minds I North Carolina has a number
of check marks next to it doesn't it
does yes there the the Carolinas seem to
be uh it just keeps popping up and
you'll be well protected at least in in
North Carolina potentially from people
who have the wrong genitals from being
in a public bathroom with you which I
know is like a really big concern
because it's been such an issue in your
life yes if and if I ever had children
if they were to run into a problem like
that I know that they would just turn
into Hitler immediately yes so we can't
have that now and uh not like we have
laws protecting kids from sexual assault
otherwise you know we really need hb2
but maybe you could work from within the
system and sort of try to change what's
going on I'd be happy to help turn a
place like the carolina's blue it would
be uh maybe I could dedicate my life to
that yet could happen in North Carolina
student sooner than later like three
months from now yeah let's take a break
suggestions for Louis will keep of
showing them and and uh having Louis
evaluate them for you gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com /
tdps